[Music]
pastor mark the question is about
deuteronomy chapter 28. the blessings
and curses right so it talks about
israel and if they follow god's commands
then he would bless them
in certain ways
can we claim those bible verses as
promises for ourself or was it only for
them
we claim the bible promises generally
for ourselves
obedience brings blessings disobedience
brings cursings now it doesn't mean if
you
get sick you're cursed it doesn't mean
if you have economic difficulties you're
cursed
but god was giving us a principle in
deuteronomy chapter 28 and the
deuteronomy chapter 28 story is
that by the grace of god if you're
obedient to god you will be faith you
will be blessed by god
that principle is also given in the book
of galatians
it's galatians
and verse 7 8 and 9 and the bible gives
you that same principle in the new
testament as that we have in the old
testament it's galatians
and chapter 6
and scripture puts it this way be not
deceived god is not mocked whatever man
sows he's going to reap
for he that soweth to the flesh shall
reap of flesh of corruption he that
soweth to the spirit
shall of the spirit reap everlife
everlasting so it's this idea of sowing
and reaping you you sow corn seed you're
going to reap corn you sow tomato seed
you're going to reap tomatoes if you sow
kindness and love throughout this world
you're going to receive that back you're
going to receive the blessings of god
and the challenge here is that we live
in an evil world a wicked world a sinful
world so it is true the bad things
happen to good people but we will
receive god's blessings they may be the
blessing of peace they may be the
blessing of joy
i know people that were physically
afflicted one of my dear friends joan
hermann who i met early in my ministry
was paralyzed with polio from her neck
down
she had to
to uh learn to paint with a with a
paintbrush in her mouth mat she had to
learn to type with a mouth stick
but she was one of the most joyful
people that i ever known in my life so
did she have blessings yes were they
physical blessings not necessarily she
was studying the bible with 15 or 20
people she'd put her bible above her
her stick in her mouth and she would
turn the pages of the bible so so was
she blessed oh yes did deuteronomy come
true for her yes but was her life easy
certainly not yeah and do you think
if we know to do something and we choose
not to do it you think god can take away
some of the protection he does certainly
certainly we walk out of his protection
right so it's not only he takes it away
it's we walk out of it
it is that
once we know what to do and we don't do
it we put ourself on a path that god
cannot
endorse
the evil that we've done
by sending good angels to
protect us
in our own choice now i'm sure god sends
angels to protect us we make wrong
decisions all the time but if we persist
in that course we actually deny god the
ability to help us as as he really could
or should right appreciate that answer
hey everybody matt gray here media
director for hopeless365 don't go yet
make sure that you subscribe and click
the bell so you get notified of the next
video in this series and i think you
should check out these other videos over
there i think you'll like those as well
see ya